monsieur le premier ministre la guerre
en syrie dure depuis quatre ans outre
des centaines de milliers de morts il ya
au moins quatre millions de réfugiés
aujourd'hui dans deux ans en turquie qui
vivent dans une situation épouvantable
des centaines de milliers d'entre eux
veulent s'apprête à venir en europe via
la turquie
dans ce contexte nos concitoyens
espérait beaucoup des rencontres de new
york la semaine dernière en marge de
l'assemblée générale des nations unies
entre le président de la république
française et un certain nombre de grands
chefs d'états américains russes iraniens
en particulier
ces rencontres ont bien eu lieu mais
quel en est le résultat
comme à son habitude françois hollande a
choisi de coller à barack obama et
continue d'exiger le départ du président
syrien bachar el-assad comme préalable à
toute négociation ce qui condamne
naturellement toute perspective de
règlement diplomatique mieux et fait
sans précédent le quai d'orsay vient de
saisir la justice française en accusant
explicitement le dirigeant syrien de
crimes de guerre et les crimes contre
l'humanité ceux qui ferment
définitivement la porte à toute
négociation avec le régime
et pendant ce temps les russes bombarde
et comme on pouvait s'y attendre les
premiers incidents aériens ont commencé
hier avec la turquie alliés de l'otan
dont la politique en syrie est pourtant
des plus troubles dans ces conditions
monsieur le premier ministre
la guerre ne peut que continuer et
s'étendre l'état italique lui se
renforce chaque jour davantage et étend
son influence en direction de l'irak et
en direction du golfe
face à cette poudrière la politique de
la france est devenue pardonnez-moi
parfaitement illisible
tout semble se passer entre russes et
américains tandis que nous passons nous
paraissons totalement alignée et sur
washington et sur ryad alors que l'appel
de la diplomatie française au contraire
devraient s'efforcer de rassembler tous
les grands acteurs pour trouver une
solution
d'où cette question que je vous pose son
alignement au nom des républicains
pouvez vous nous expliquer ce que vous
êtes en train de faire et où vous
essayez de conduire notre pays merci
monsieur lellouche
la parole est à monsieur le ministre est
rangé ray développement international
oui monsieur pierre lellouche en tout
cas je peux essayer de vous l'expliquer
l'objectif est le suivant la france
étant indépendantes indépendante
nous sommes indépendants des états unis
nous sommes indépendants de la russie en
revanche nous ne sommes pas indépendants
de l'intérêt de la france et des
français et c'est ça notre ligne
directrice en syrie monsieur le député
lellouche le objectif est quoi
premièrement frappé le groupe terroriste
dash nous l'avons fait en irak depuis
maintenant un an
nous le faisons depuis quelques semaines
en syrie puisque c'était une affaire de
légitime défense
deuxièmement obtenir l'arrêt des
bombardements par dynamite du de bachar
el-assad vis-à-vis de la population
civile et une résolution sera déposé en
ce sens
troisièmement comme il n'y a pas
seulement une action militaire à mener
mais évidemment une action politique
plaidé agir pour la transition politique
eh oui monsieur le député lellouche
faire en sorte qu'à la fin
monsieur bachar al assad ne soit plus
hauts responsables et non pas seulement
pour une raison morale parce qu'il est
responsable de 80 % des 250 mille morts
de syrie il faut quand même se le
rappeler mais pour des raisons
d'efficacité car si on prétend comme
vous le faites à juste titre comprendre
la situation en syrie
il faut bien comprendre que le meilleur
alignement du terrorisme ce sont les
exactions menées depuis quatre ans par
monsieur bachar al assad et qui n'est
pas possible que le bourreau d'un peuple
soit proposée comme étant l'avenir de ce
peuple et c'est cela nous discutons avec
l'iran
monsieur lellouche que nous avons
rencontrés à new york avec les états
unis d'amérique que j'ai rencontrée par
l'intermédiaire de monsieur qui rit avec
le président poutine qui était en france
avec les arabes
avec lecture avec l'ensemble des parties
prenantes car nous croyons nous envers
et contre tout à la nécessité de la paix
merci monsieur le ministre la par an